you must have met people who had you
tattooed on them actually I have a new
lease it this is more common than we
think but the weirdest one was Danny
Trejo you know the act the actor Danny
Trejo from the oldest action films he
was actually in prison for many years
for he's now an actor yes and he was in
prison for many years for robbing banks
and increasing he that took himself a
huge tattoo of a woman here and when he
he learned how to act in prison and then
when he got out of prison he started
working and of course he landed on the
movie that my first movie that I did and
when he saw me for the first time they
told me you're gonna meet this prisoner
that is now an actor and he's was a
little bit afraid and when I saw him for
the first time he saw me and he ran
towards me and ripped his shirt off and
he said I knew you before I knew you I
grant you before I knew you and sure
enough there was a picture of a woman
that looks exactly like me the body was
a little bit better but less exactly
like me in his chest Wow
yes yeah he's very peculiar and he said
I just got out of jail and I'm happy but
for you I'm gonna rob another Bank
for okay we were up to 30 animals I saw
this little guy whose job it was
it's the little guy whose sole job it
was if I could work out was to run out
with a bicycle pump in a bucket and as
soon as they went action